hi i'm kylie bunbury hi i'm hannah john
carman
hi i'm harry lloyd i am uh
just fun friendly and we're here to take
the buzzfeed which brave new world
character are you quizz
first how would your bffs describe you
empathetic adventurous analytical
loyal bold or helpful i think i'm i
think i'm a few of those things
yeah but what would you yeah how would
your friends describe
you i think for me
yeah i think my friends would call me
analytical i mean even though i'm
actually
much more adventurous and loyal i think
my
friends would describe me as adventurous
that's cool i think i don't know what i
would say
maybe bold loyal was probably up there
as well most because most of my friends
are
all from like secondary school from like
11 so
that's loyal that's definitely loyal
choose a dystopian tv show or movie
to watch black mirror handmaid's tale
westworld blade runner mad max
fury road or snow piercer um i'm gonna
go black mirror
uh yeah i'm i'm team charlie brooker i'm
gonna go black mirror to you
uh that's yeah that's my answer as well
you know what
you guys are loyal yeah
i uh i'll take blade runner i think
which brave new world character would
you
fight alongside mustafa monde
madsen henry foster linda
sheila director i mean it depends who
you're
fighting linda i think would be helpful
in a scrap if she had to be
um i think the staffer for me kicked
some ass
i think i'll take sheila i'm going with
sheila too she's badass
i i'd also go sheila mostly also because
i just want to hang out with
kate fleetwood yep which house would you
want to visit in the savagelands park
house of want house of futility house of
consequence
house of monogamy house of want is
basically a supermarket and seeing how
the savages used to kill each other on
uh black friday house of futility is
like a hospital house of consequences of
prison and as a monogamy is that kind of
fake
wedding church ceremony um i guess i'd
want to visit
house of want because maybe i could get
some items
get some soups you can get savage
[Music]
as well because i think supermarket but
kind of
like friday-esque is very savage and i
think that's just kind of the
excitement in me i'd go house of
monogamy i love a wedding
i don't even mind what they are i don't
want to go to one
i would i would take house of
consequence because
to the new londoners the prison they
wouldn't really understand it
to listen to on john's walkman dancing
queen by abba
thank you next by ariana grande
come on eileen um
by dexy's midnight runners bad guy by
billy eilish
go your own way by fleetwood mac or
god's plan by drake
i'd go with dancing queen abba my mum
and i when we were younger just
always listen to all the abba vinyls all
the time
whenever we like decorate the rooms and
the bedrooms in the house and everything
so it gives me good memories
yeah i was gonna go ariana grande but i
think maybe i should go
her fleetwood mac mine's fleet with mag
too i i'm
i'm i'm always abba i actually i saw in
the new year
like dancing to abba sort of right
before midnight
and um made a promise that i would go
dancing
loads during 2020. um it's been a bit
tricky so far
but i've been doing a lot of it at home
and now i've been like
abby's been up there with like what to
dance to it makes me feel good
all right choose a book you had to read
in high school great gatsby little women
1984
catcher in the rye lord of the flies
wuthering heights
lord of the flies i have an admission
though um lord of the flies was what i
was supposed
to read and i i watched the film
at least at least you didn't watch a lot
of the rings i did read great gatsby and
capture the riot when i was about 16 and
they were both i've read them both again
and they both still stand up i'll take
catcher in the rye because they haven't
made a film of it
so there's something kind of special
about it what did you do carly i did
lord of advice
pick something important from brave new
world
soma johns walkman savagelands park
the cast system indra the barrier
i'm going to say purely just for helms
the soma she really needs it
it's one item that she really wants i'm
going to take
indra my friend recently booked an
airbnb from someone called
indra that's a little weird really i
imagine it's an
incredible house just because of
franny i think i'm gonna go selma as
well i'm massively sentimental
so it's john's walkman i made a playlist
that was everything that i imagined to
be on that
walkman and i used to i'm still
listening to the playlist
it's it's really good is it is it all
the same songs that they put in the show
some of them were what i imagined would
be in moments
one of them is in there
i got john i'm a savage
what i got lanina crown
yeah there's my face
hello i got lanina crown
[Music]
and i got i have no idea you got cjx16
you got c jack 60. hard working loyal
pretty quiet but good at tidying yeah
great
we did it we did it thank you for giving
us the quiz buzzfeed
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you